efectivamente ha sido una alegría de
latinoamérica para abrir los mundiales
de atletismo en esta edición en el año
2022 y estos últimos cinco kilómetros
fueron determinantes para que kimberly
garcía que había ganado medalla de
bronce en omán y que apenas en mayo
había ganado la medalla de oro en la
internacional del río maior portugal
pusiera bien la marca como decías de 1
2658 y aquí lo importante es como mejoró
desde mayo para acá porque precisamente
en mayo en esa internacional de portugal
había puesto 132 42 es decir casi 5
minutos por debajo del registro que
termina dándole la primera medalla de
oro en toda la historia a perú en
campeonatos mundiales adultos pero que
dijo kimberly garcía después de ser la
primera campeona mundial de oro con 2022
lo escuchamos y lo vemos a continuación
con
la competencia siempre tenemos de
referencia a las más fuertes las chinas
australia españa y otra alguna chica más
que nunca que subestimar no porque todas
vienen muy preparadas teníamos veníamos
con las expectativas bastante altas de
evitarnos del 1 al 5 y la verdad que fue
mucho mejor el resultado cuando medalla
de oro la primera vez que quedando así
que no sabía qué hacer no sabía cómo
reaccionar la verdad es que no lo podía
creer lo único que fue
ir donde mi entrenador y darle un gran
abrazo porque en verdad trabajamos muy
duro para esta medalla juan pero fundía
importante para los atletas
latinoamericanos es debido a que también
humberto mansilla el chileno consiguió
hacer historia para su país y el relevo
mixto dominicano consiguió demostrar que
es uno de los mejores del mundo
así es 733 fue la marca de humberto
mansilla en el último lanzamiento de las
preliminares de esta mañana en oregón
esto hizo que se metiera en el puesto
número 11 y de esta manera conseguir la
primera final histórica del lanzamiento
de martillo para el team chile nunca
había ocurrido esto para el el país
austral y después bueno hacer de
referencia lo de lo que hace el relevo
mixto dominicano que termine
imponiéndose con 3 13 22 la tercera
mejor marca de clasificación para que
esta noche se dispute el podio cada vez
esta carga desaprueba el récord del
mundo lo destruyó una vez más el equipo
de los eeuu con 3 11 75 lo que hizo
clasificarse en la primera posición es
decir para latinoamérica hoy puede ser
doblete si el equipo dominicano ese de
relevo mixto que hizo de las suyas
durante esta temporada que incluso ganó
el campeonato del americano y que tiene
entre sus filas a una cerradura
extraordinaria y medallista de plata
olímpica como madrid y paulino pudieran
ser entonces dos las medallas que
latinoamérica termine consiguiendo en
esta primera jornada
el campeonato mundial de atletismo que
se lleva a cabo en aragón